hola a todos ahora vamos a hablar del
rotacional en tres dimensiones y para
hacerlo vamos a partir del ejemplo en
dos dimensiones que usamos cuando
estamos desarrollando la intuición y
sabemos que el flujo que anima vamos
aquí de este campo vectorial tiene una
rotación antihorario verdad del lado
derecho y horaria arriba verdad así que
vamos a tomar este campo vectorial que
espero que ya tenga cierta intuición de
él y vamos a incrustarlo en el espacio
de tres dimensiones en el plano el
quillá así que aquí tenemos una copia
del plano x y esta es una muestra que
parece distinta pero esencialmente
representa al mismo campo vectorial y de
hecho es bueno escribir cómo se definen
dos dimensiones que entonces este campo
vectorial en realidad es una función que
depende de xy de y en verdad es un campo
vectorial ve que depende de xy belle y
tiene dos componentes la primera
componente la podemos calcular como de
kubica menos 9 y y la siguiente
componente es x cúbica menos 9 x así que
si nos fijamos en esto digamos empezamos
a pensar en la rotación del fluido o del
flujo asociado con el entonces esto se
ve en tres dimensiones verdad y es
natural tratar de describir esta
rotación no solo con un número en cada
punto como ya sabemos sino pensar
también en un vector para cada punto que
nos dé la rotación así que cuando
hacemos esto vamos a tratar de asociar
un vector en cada punto distinto del
espacio verdad y que nos indique la
rotación del fluido y obtenemos algo
como esto y ahora parece más complicado
porque tenemos dos campos vectoriales
uno en el plano xy y otro perpendicular
así que vamos a tratar de desmenuzar el
problema tenemos cuatro regiones
circuladas aquí verdad aquí tenemos una
rotación que va en sentido antihorario
verdad y esto lo podríamos pensar
utilizando la regla de la mano derecha
aquí está la la imagen entonces pensamos
en que doblamos nuestros dedos en la
dirección de la rotación y cuando
levantamos el pulgar entonces esa sería
la dirección de los vectores que
describen la rotación así que si hacemos
esto aquí podríamos pensar que doblamos
nuestros dedos verdad como sigue la
rotación y entonces levantamos nuestro
pulgar y obtenemos un
vector que apunte en la dirección
positiva de z verdad así que por eso es
que tenemos en esta región vectores que
apuntan hacia arriba ok entonces qué
ocurre por ejemplo en otro punto digamos
qué pasaría si estamos por ejemplo aquí
arriba verdad entonces si nosotros
tratamos de girar nuestros dedos
siguiendo la rotación entonces nuestro
punto pulgar apunta hacia abajo verdad
en la dirección negativa de z y es lo
que vemos en este campo vectorial aquí
verdad porque debajo de este círculo
tenemos vectores que apuntan justamente
hacia abajo en toda esa región verdad
entonces si hacemos esto en cada punto
verdad al menos podríamos tener más o
menos una idea de cómo es la rotación en
cada punto del espacio y asignarle un
vector verdad así que vamos a tratar de
continuar y describir digamos con una
función lo que es el rotacional verdad
porque sabemos cómo calcular el
rotacional en dos dimensiones porque si
le ponemos nombre a nuestras dos
funciones componentes digamos pq verdad
entonces el rotacional en dos
dimensiones de este campo vectorial
vamos a ponerlo el rotacional
en dos dimensiones del campo vectorial
ve por supuesto como función de xy de y
entonces esto es igual a la derivada
parcial de nuestra segunda componente
que en este caso es q verdad con
respecto a x la parcial de q respecto de
x ya éste le tenemos que restar la
derivada parcial de la primera
componente respecto de verdad es la
parcial de t con respecto de g así que
aquí tenemos el rotacional en dos
dimensiones vamos a tratar de derivar
derivamos esta primera respecto de x que
es una derivada tradicional verdad
entonces tendríamos 3x cuadrada menos 9
esa es la derivada la primera derivada
verdad menos la derivada de p con
respecto de ya que es exactamente igual
verdad vamos a tener menos la derivada
de aquí arriba que es 3 y cuadrada
verdad 3 d cuadrada menos
y entonces estos dos se cancelan aquí
tenemos que estos dos nueves
se cancelan entonces simplemente nos
queda 3x cuadrada 3x cuadrada menos 3 y
cuadrada bueno y esto qué significa aquí
tenemos una cantidad de escalar asociada
al campo verdad y tenemos todos estos
vectores azules que nos indican la
dirección de la rotación y estos en
realidad son vectores ahora bien la
rotación está ocurriendo únicamente en
el plano xy que es perpendicular al eje
z y todos estos vectores sólo van a
tener una componente 7 es decir la
tercera verdad así que podríamos pensar
que el rotacional digamos el rotacional
ya no es en dos dimensiones simplemente
es el rotacional de nuestro campo
vectorial ve cómo funciona a través de
xy de y ahora no va a ser un valor
escalar verdad ahora va a ser un vector
pero va a ser un vector que describe a
estos que tenemos de color azul y que
solo tiene un componente z verdad las
primeras tres las primeras dos
componentes son cero así que en la
última simplemente será 3x cuadrada
3 cuadrada y esto es digamos lo que
podríamos pensar como un prototipo del
rotacional en tres dimensiones porque en
realidad de este campo vectorial ve pues
no es muy tridimensional que digamos
verdad solo vive en el plano xy sólo
toma entradas x y ya así que lo que
vamos a hacer es tratar de extender esta
idea vamos a tratar de ver cómo se ve
esto en tres dimensiones y cómo
podríamos tratar de entender la rotación
de un campo vectorial en tres
dimensiones y eso es lo que haremos en
el próximo vídeo